and I advise I lost my mind about
boots because I made the plant take advantage of it for
shows have good take National Diane
Kruger side if it's on the outskirts or and I
got angry problem is problem Messi
Highlights some time I heard some of the
Highway Unicorn on the tracks Wonderland
quotes For You And Your installation and
Don't Worry please don't you tell you
one Being very common practices to Pure
water from the Crowds Out Boy Infinity
on Land is a gray Strange but we always
say everyone has a store Joke is here is more
fast how can you see work
can stay at home of São João da
Highway 18 Sound of water Dog Netflix
undergoes test drive and
[Music]
I am I gave crooked and Clean of this
Lake and Lake is right there were Lost
basic is  a cubic effect Tite revealed
a string between the make some Changes
to love the Highway and you get to shops
shoulders laugh and string is what
G1
G1 and
the shoes on the web about Rafael
Bittencourt doesn't have a top coat detail
It turned On
the nature of my apologies
Vaqueiro romantic songs staying for now
the money goes  wanting to see the
spoons version of now if it ended up
clearly close to descending leaving
now that they don't follow the rest that was
a
And there
G1
Andthere
And there
eu sou da ru Poder Lines na rede and his
body to be Open relay comem Super
Saiyan 3 Running at one Things One
Piece Maiden sign of her way to put the
Hands of gold
the sertanejo still Sunny Days we can test
out West Wing
goes to the  bathroom
now what time am I in a group A
Hey
G1
Hey And then
the king smiled and opened Action Place will
die Within This section is he is sure to
reflect on water flowing to be honest
you do  not Hide Your Heart of Land sun
Robert Erich Frost PS2 Stevie Wond  er the
garden At Work your way up and down to
the lake Didier national were the
web draws of Lake effect with some
pics to be next thing we not sure
what Point is what we do with water and
Risk Of Rain water Swift and the lake
and e are beautiful And stable and
Everything in between the water Flow
Speed top 10 Returns and Sweet tip sabe in Ro
ert's corner do no
make a beautiful day After milk
n front of Katniss slow workspace disco
nt is half a bleque bridge Oops I use it now F
ow in  for the kill to have its end
that the Highway 61 plan
the cells of the hours end panel is that
the born and box Jorge is now cyber
Residencial Penha Alves Lopes Tracker
Within the cinema and videos will love
you and select Game of questions Words
like I love  is in the air which is one
day I had some questions to get married
Life video I made for you Honey Burst
António Jorge a
um Ok I
have Jorge Pereira
I get 60
and I don't use the internet
Yes yes I've seen it in Germany several
I have spent several times already working in the Azores
I had almost three years working there at the
base of Lajes which is on Terceira
Azores Island and in Paris places in Portugal
I walked many years in various directions in
Portugal
and this is where I was born and that is  it's
our roots we have to like everything by the
way we all pull there is a vacancy a
smile even if we are emigrants but
we go to the other side of the world
we always come back when we were born already you
we already miss our play
and i am currently retired from my
profession and what  I do continue to
work working the land I like
Agriculture I like to be entertained with
the However it is not because it is a means of
livelihood that is but but I feel
happy working on the land have animals not
being entertained with everything I was busy
I feel  happy like that
and that's how we were born we were born
in a time of crisis that is not so much that
at the time it was more of a crisis that now there
weren't so many possibilities when i was
little use of mine  generation and we are left
with this one with this context soul of Never
We are stopped is always working
entertained working studying working
in agriculture having animals in the contract
thank you this is our day to day life
Yes, the relationship we had
here was very great  it's one it's one it's an
affinity that leaves us that we
miss because since we were kids we were
raised here and I my cousins from three
to four families go here kids
othing at home that was different that
verything has changed a lot tea the landscape is every
hing has changed  in other words But we leave
a mark it is engraved in ourselves for
you for you youth up to
school age this is where we spent our
days this is where our parents
used to eat and she spent here our
affairs are not jokes  with
Instagram control give everything inhabited it is
habitable during the day
and in the summer I slept Sometimes the night
ended here when we had
the corn rye cereal droughts is  I only
slept in the summer I didn't remember
we had the house in the population in 3D
the cultivation of corn with you almost everything from the
movie of what we here consume the corn
beans lettuces onions potatoes all
all the vegetables that we
need cultivate all this
hello all  what is what is
cultivated here with you?  Sunday we
're just right there eating the animals and
little else it's not a day to work the
lands it's not a day for us it's a day to
respect a subject I'm Catholic and
about Sunday that's it
and you made me feel very happy and and
I'm glad new people came here
that I think are very
nice and it's gratifying it's
gratifying because they're young are
young and they like nature they like
what a lot of people don't
like  probably because not in our current era,
that is, youth doesn't
adapt very much to these circumstances I think
that it's very gratifying for
you to be here for nature for the
benefit of nature
today and for everything it brings us brings
more joy and leftovers  happiest
we know is here Someone who likes
us and we like them I think it's
very good I think it's very good
What's Up
[Music]
What is it  I like it all we
miss it here is a very special place in a
special place because
the bonds that the bonds of children the
bonds of our parents our grandparents study
leaves us leaves us everything we leave everything
that is good makes one happy here and
walking  here it makes us happy we are a little
homesick, right
and sometimes there was a second depending on the
ventilation being old this one where it was
already a lot and if the winds, for example,
wind from the north we have a good weather
because the north wind brings good weather  if you
hear here the train is heard very well,
either from the south south or west it brings
a rain bring a cell phone
and it is for me to support them because it is part
of my education In other words I support the without
second intention because they arrived here they
need  support because I think
helping others is an
added value for us it is our
identity everywhere doing
people well we are identified doing
people well we are identified
because our grandparents and books say
our parents that  no one lives well with the
bad of others, that is, doing well
we sleep peacefully we walk around
happy and not feeling happy and
that way it was going to be everyone
I like it I like it a lot I have I
bought this cordless chainsaw because
I was forbidden to work with
electric tools  and with chainsaws
as I was able to implement a country Maker a
CDI and I have a restriction and however
this is one of the solutions that I came up with
to not be stopped we have to
stop  anjar always a solution for us
to continue or it is not stopped
just like I bought the chainsaw I bought
other tools There is everything battery powered
to continue doing some things
I can work the battery cannot
be battery powered electricity
and depending on what you want to
do right  because the tractor is needed to
stop for everything for everything to work
agriculture to work the forest if
these roses and then it is really needed
I think so
Yes it is to protect me from the heat of the
sun or help I use it is in agriculture
here we  we weren't but we can if we
go to another place to another place we
don't take bananas anymore Well I feel it's a
covered area or for a family lunch no
longer talking to Banana that thing in your
place is
and will probably be from
home
I have one I have one  message
for all people to fight for the good of the
world for peace for the world's ecosystem
that what is sorely missed also
people do not respect for  They are in
plastic objects everything everywhere nobody
respects anything where appropriate places
to put all this respect
nature which is very good I think
this is important and to see more love
between people is also very
important
to be more friends with each other  of others
less Obvious because the world is
teaching us to be like that but even
so people seem to have learned
I too have my mistakes I'm not
perfect but I try to be better every day
and this was the interview with our
friend George that  it's been really
amazing support for us I hope you
enjoyed the video If you want you can
support me at Zen support point protecan.
With a and see you in the next video a